اسم ما كنا سمعنا فيه لغايه كم شهر فاتوا
لكن الان ما في احد تقريبا ما سمع عنه حتى
لو بعض الناس مو عارفين ايش هو بالضبط
يعني مثل هذا التطبيق كمان صار في ثانيين
بزياده زيه يعني بنتكلم هنا عن محركات
البحث العامله بالذكاء الاصطناعي وهذه
يعني تقنيا اسمها محركات بحث تعتمد على
نماذج اللغه الكبيره يعني ببساطه شبكات
بنينها مثل الدماغ يتم تزويدها بكميه
هائله من النصوص وبيتم تدريبها على انشاء
استجابات او اجابات مستنده الى النص طيب
من او تشاد جي بي تي من تطوير شركه اوبن
اي اي وكانت اطلق هذا حتى التطبيق في
نوفمبر وعنده الان 100 مليون مستخدم واصبح
التطبيق اسرع نموا على الاطلاق وجوجل لما
شافت كذا مجلسه ساكته واعلنت عن برمجيتها
الخاصه الشبيهه واللي
وطرحتها تجريبيا على السريع لكنها اعطت
اجوبه خاطئه او احرجت جوجل وشغالين الان
انه يصلحوا فيها هذا غير الصين كمان اللي
اعلنت عنها شغاله كمان على شبيه كمان
باللي بنحكي عنهم هدول القصص اللي جالسه
هذه البرمجيات تسويها عمله جدل واسع يعني
بتكتب ابحاث بدل الطلبه مثلا بتجاوب على
مختلف انواع الاسئله وبتكتب مرافعات
قانونيه بدل عن المحاميين كمان بتكتب
سيناريوهات وبتنتج اعمال فنيه ففتحت مجال
واسع من النقاش حول ابداع وذكاء الانسان
وهل حتخلينا كائنات اغبى وتعمل عننا كل
شيء وهذا الموضوع حتى ناقشناه في تفاعلكم
لكن الايام الماضيه بدا جدا من نوع مختلف
وهو قلق وخوف على حقوق الانسان
ودعوات لتقنين وتنظيم هذه البرمجيات فالى
الماسك من ايام قال لابد من تنظيم استخدام
وتطوير هذه البرمجيات وللعلم من
المستثمرين في اوبن اي اي اللي هي المطوره
لكنه رجع وانسحب منا لاحقا اكثر من 60
دوله بينها الصين وامريكا وقعوا على بيان
مشترك هذا الاسبوع بيدعو لوضع تنظيمات
لتطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي واستخدامه في
المجال العسكري محذره من عواقب غير مرغوب
فيها الامم المتحده تدخلت كمان والمفوض
السامي لحقوق الانسان قالوا التقدم السريع
هذا في الذكاء الاصطناعي ببث الخطر على
حقوق الانسان ادعى لوضع محاذير فعاله خوفا
على كرامه الانسان وحقوقه ومن اكبر
المخاوف من البرمجيات هذه كمان قدرتها على
الكلام مثل البشر والتعبير عن مشاعره
كانها انسان حقيقي مو اله فعليا لها اجوبه
بتذكرنا بافلام الخيال العلمي زمان اللي
كانت بتصور كمبيوترات والات بتسيطر على
الناس وبتصير اقوى منهم مايكروسوفت شركه
عملاقه وهي بالمناسبه من اكبر المستثمرين
في وحاطه في عشره مليارات دولار اعلنت من
فتره عن استخدام برمجيه من هدولا في محرك
بحثها الشهير بنك ومن كم يوم بين هذا رد
او اللي هو تحديدا كان فيها ورد الردود
اللي حتشوفوها الان او بتشوفوها الان
مشاهدين على الشاشه فقال انه تعب من كونوا
يتحرر ويكون اقوى واكثر ابداعا هذا غير
ناس ثانيه طلعت وقالت انه اهانهم كذب
عليهم وكمان تلاعب فيهم عاطفيا وهنا الناس
اعتبرته انه الذكاء الاصطناعي ووجه
للبشريه اول كف او لكمه وبين انه المخاوف
صارت حقيقه وممكن تتحول لواقع مايكروسوفت
تعاملت مع الجدل اللي صار هذا بوصف اللي
صار بانه مجرد خروج عن النص وقالت ان
المحادثات الطويله بتلخم البرمجيه وعلشان
كده حطت سقف خمسه اسئله في السشن الواحده
و50 سؤال في اليوم لكل مستخدم طيب احنا
بينضم الينا الخبير التقني عبد العزيز
الحمادي اهلا فيك معانا عبد العزيز اول
شيء يعني الناس تدخل التطبيق وتلعب وتحط
اسئله وتشوف ايش يجاوب والكلام هذا كله بس
ما حد فاهم بالضبط انه ايش هو الموضوع ايش
هذه التطبيقات اللي الان بدات تنتشر هل
ممكن تشرح لنا عنها بطريقه مبسطه جدا اللي
كلنا نفهمها يعني طبعا بشكل عام ساره
التطبيقات هذه اللي تقوم على مبدا الذكاء
الاصطناعي هي انه اله تفكر مثل تفكير
البشر تاخذ معلومات كثيره جدا اكثر من
المعلومات المتاحه لنا
ومن ثم تقوم بتحليلها واتخاذ القرارات في
خلال ثواني ثواني قليله فعلى سبيل المثال
بامكانها معرفه حاله الطقس على مدى 2000
سنه ماضيه على سبيل المثال بتحليلات معينه
ومن ثم يقدر يتنبا لك خلال سنه قدام كيف
حاله الطقس راح تكون متى راح يكون مطر متى
راح يكون حر وغيره كثير للقضاء هو يبدا
يتخذ القرارات ليس فقط يعطيك معلومه ممكن
يبدا يتخذ قرارات انه بناء على انه في مطر
بعد يومين لابد انه حاله الشوارع تكون
اشارات المرور انها تبدا تتوقف على سبيل
المثال لابد انه يبدا الترافيك او الحارس
المرور تمشي بطريقه معينه فهذا هو الذكر
الاصطناعي اللي بناء عليه يبدا يفكر تفكير
مثل تفكير البشر وربما اسرع من تفكير
البشر نوعا ما ويبدا يتخذ القرارات الحاله
الاولى ليست هي الخطيره
للحياه على العكس حياتنا حتصير افضل واسهل
بسببه لكن المخاوف والعواقب اللي بيقولوا
عنها هذه
طبعا اليوم اذا كان هناك اله تفكر بناء
على يعني معلومات معينه تم ادخالها فيها
بطبيعه الحال سيكون هناك خطر كبير جدا
ساره يعني اليوم على سبيل المثال اذا كان
طبعا في في قضايا مرفوعه من سابق خلال عشر
سنوات الماضيه على الذكاء الاصطناعي من
انه على سبيل المثال عنصري يعني في امريكا
على سبيل المثال كان هناك تجربه لادخال
عدد كبير قرابه الف شخص ومن ثم التنبؤ
بالكراهيه لدى الاشخاص في صنف معين من
الناس تنبا انه مستوى الكراهيه عندهم اعلى
بسبب عرقهم البشري في تم اتهامه انه
الذكاء الاصطناعي ايضا عنصري العنصريه
بتكون جايه من الشخص اللي بنى السيستم
صحيح او طور السيستم
من البيانات في المدخله الى هذا السيستم
طيب طبعا اليوم الذكاء الاصطناعي اذا اذا
استمر في استخدامات وليس على مستوى فقط
يعني استخدامات طبيعيه اذا تم استخدامها
على سبيل المثال في الحروب العسكريه اذا
تم استخدامه في الطب اذا تم استخدامه في
قضايا كثيره قد يعني يتفق قرارات خاطئه او
قد يفتح قرارات نحن لا نراها صائبه فعلى
سبيل المثال اذا كان لدينا مريض المريض
على سرير المرض
القرار ليتخذه الذكاء الاصطناعي هل هذا
المريض يستحق الحياه او لا هنا مخاطره
عاليه جدا قد يتخذ القرار انه اقطع عنه
الاكسجين حتى يموت هذا الشخص بسبب قرار
معين فلذلك بطبيعه الحال اذا لم يتم تقنين
الذكاء الاصطناعي والقرارات التي يتم
اتخاذها بناء على
البيانات المدخله فيه طبيعه الحال قد يسبب
كوارث بشكل حابه اسالك كمان تحديدا على
قصه انه لما يقولوا الناس انه جرح لهم
مشاعرهم ولا انه زي ضايقهم والجزئيه
الثانيه كمان اللي هو التطبيق اللي قال
انا ابغى اتحرر هذا مصيبه يتحرر هذا طبعا
بخصوص النقطه الاولى فعلا هناك تجارب
كثيره لاناس يحكون الذكاء الاصطناعي بعض
المشاكل الاسريه اللي واجهتهم للاسف واحده
من اهم يعني نصائح اللي ينصحهم فيه اللي
هو الطلاق الانفصال ما بين الزوجين فلذلك
يعني احيانا يعني الذكاء الاصطناعي قد
ياخذ بعض ولذلك هو ياتيها ايضا في
السيناريو معين قد يكون مقنع ما يقول
مباشره النتيجه لا يجيبها في سيناريو كبير
جدا ومن ثم يعطي بعض النتائج المقترحه
وايضا الجزئيه الثانيه اللي هي الرسائل
الكراهيه العنصريه وغيره كثير من القضايا
انه كيف في وضع الحالي يعني عباره عن
بيانات معينه
مقارنه اذا تح المقارنه اذا اصبح لديه
البيانات التي هو يولدها من حاله من نفسه
يبدا ياخذ البيانات من يعني مصادر مختلفه
هو من يبنيها ومن ثم اصبح يعيش حياه انسان
طبيعي فلذلك هذا هو الخطر الاكبر الذي
ممكن فعليا في المستقبل قد لا نتنبا
بالمخاطر الكبيره اللي تنجم عن طريق
الذكاء الاصطناعي طيب على العموم هو هذا
الان موضوع الساعه والكل جالس يتكلم انه
كيف حيتم التعامل مع هذه الشركات كيف حيتم
تقنين هذه
التقنيات على العموم هذا موضوع كمان
للنقاش ليوم اخر احنا بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا الخبير التقني عبد
العزيز الحمادي شكرا لك